Dr. Kevin Conner's again, this second presentation of Lyme disease is going to be a little bit
briefer than the first one, and we're talking about the three different phases of Lyme disease.
So remember what I said last week is that there's different authors that classify Lyme disease differently.
So my classification of Lyme disease is the acute phase. That's the phase that's still treatable by antibiotics,
and it is where the Borrelia is still bloodborne or in the extracellular spaces.
It has yet to enter into the inside of the cell as soon as even one bacteria enters inside of a cell
you have missed the acute phase, you are now into the chronic phase in my classification.
So as a review, Lyme disease is carried by this little bugger right there.
I've had Lyme disease twice. The second time I had Lyme disease, I could not find the tick.
I never found the tick. I never had a rash. So I just got super, super sick. That second time that I had Lyme disease.
And because I almost never get sick, it reminded me so much of my previous Lyme disease about 19 years, previous to this time.
But for the life of me, I could not think that I had Lyme disease. I initially thought I have to have food poisoning.
I was traveling north to a second clinic I had in Northern Minnesota. It was early, I think it was in March. I had really been outside.
At that time I was living in the city. It wasn't exposed to any deer ticks at all.
It didn't even dawn on me that I had Lyme disease for several days. A bead really, really sick.
I thought this has to be food poisoning. It didn't act like the flu. I knew it wasn't the flu.
I thought I just assumed that it was food poisoning. I never ended up testing myself until it was probably four days into the process of, you know, just these waves of, okay, I'm feeling a little bit better too.
I am so sick, I am puking my guts out, sorry. But I was just so extremely sick.
I had, I had the severity of flu-like symptoms. I had, you know, a very high severity of the flu-like symptoms.
I've had patients that never had, never found a tick. Never had a rash. It never, remember having flu-like symptoms.
So, during their acute stage of Lyme disease, they missed all the signs. So it's just the way their body reacted.
The first time I had Lyme disease, I did find the tick. I had a spot on my belly. This was back, oh my goodness, this was back in 19.
19.5, 19.6, and so Lyme disease was, that was very well-known at that time.
And I located the tick on my belly, and there was literally a, it was if you took a red lipstick container
and you painted a bull's eye rash out about 12 inches from that spot on my belly.
And the tick was so small that when I picked it out with the tweezers, I thought it was literally a piece of pepper.
You could not see it with your naked eye. I sent it on a white piece of paper and took a little magnified glass.
I remember having to call my kids over because it was just amazing. Oh my gosh, look at this little creature.
It was just a nymph of a deer tick, and it was carrying Borrelia because I got so unbelievably sick.
And I got antibiotics that, that first time immediately, and it just literally knocked it out.
The second time, it took me again four or five days, I can't remember, before I finally figured it out that I had Lyme disease, and I got antibiotics right away that completely knocked it out.
So a cute stage Lyme is when it is, when the infection is still bloodboard, or the infection is still extracellular.
Now the Borrelia bacteria lives in this intermediate host, this deer tick, and the deer tick that infects the human, and this is what causes the Borrelia.
There are, I mean, I completely believe that your body is amazing, and there are probably thousands and thousands, hundreds of thousands of people.
Maybe that are infected with the Borrelia, and their immune system kills it before it ever causes an issue.
So, it don't overlook the ability of your immune system. However, if you're firing a hyper-TH1 response, that is going to be experienced with a fever, and chills, and feeling fatigue, and all these food-like symptoms.
That means your immune system is struggling, and the chance of you killing it with an immune response is slim to none at that point.
Now it's beautiful if you have a rash, but the majority of Lyme patients that I talk about, either say they never had a rash, or they never noticed it.
I mean, how many times maybe, maybe it's just me, but I'm not inspected my body on a daily basis.
So, if you're a male and you have a lot of body here, you're not going to see it. If you're in the head, you're not going to see a rash.
And many times you won't have the rash, like I said, many patients that I've seen never even had any symptoms. They don't even recall, even being sick.
But now they have all the symptoms of chronic Lyme, and testing them, sure enough, they do have chronic Lyme, or even an auto-immune face.
So, it's something you have to be, if you live in a Lyme area, during the tick season, you have to really be aware.
So, I tell people, if you get these types of symptoms of any type of neurological symptoms at all, Bell's palsy, that's facial paralysis of a cranial nerve, any confusion, forgetfulness, if you just notice, you're just not with it as much anymore, to these are more chronic symptoms.
But the more acute symptoms, I tell people, if you have any flu-like symptoms, you need to deal with it as if you have acute Lyme.
So, let's put it this way. If you live in a Lyme area, now, if you're living in an area where there's hardly any Lyme disease, or you've never even heard of Lyme disease, and you could look at a statistical map to find this out.
If Lyme disease is all due to you, and you're only listening to this presentation because somebody you know has Lyme disease, you probably don't live in a huge Lyme area.
But anywhere in the door, the whole eastern seaboard of the United States, I'm in a soda, a huge Lyme state, Wisconsin, Michigan, Lyme states, and Lyme disease is just rampant.
And it is Lyme season, it is tick season, meaning the spring and summer. And you have flu-like symptoms, you have to treat it as Lyme.
So, the danger of you going into your doctor and saying, I feel like I got the flu, I feel super sick, I didn't find any tick, let's pretend you didn't find any tick, no rash, but you have the flu-like symptoms.
And if your doctor says, well, and you ask them, do I have, I want to know if I have Lyme disease, I should probably get an antibiotic.
And the doctor says, well, let's run a Lyme test, you need to find another doctor. Because as we're going to talk about in later presentations, the tests for Lyme disease are highly inaccurate.
So, if it's circulated, so remember, any blood test, any blood test at all, they're taking out a viable blood from your arm.
If that bacteria, if the beryllium bacteria is not contained in that very specific vial of blood, it's going to be negative.
Okay, so the chance of it being contained in that vial of blood in the acute stage Lyme is small.
You have about a 30% chance of it being positive. Some many statistics show that Lyme acute Lyme tests are 70% chance of having a false negative.
That means it's really positive, but it reads as a negative.
So, then you're going to have a false sense that this wasn't Lyme, it will continue.
You won't get the antibiotics that you need. It will continue under chronic Lyme and could end up with autoimmune Lyme.
And I tell you, I have seen so many debilitated patients that wish they could go back and beat up their medical doctor who wouldn't give him an antibiotic at stage one.
It's unfortunate, the lack of information that most doctors have.
So, you have to find a Lyme letter, a doctor that would treat you with your symptoms. I'm sorry, but I'm old enough to know that there was a day in medicine where the doctor would examine you and treat you via your symptoms based upon their wealth of knowledge of treat other people.
Not based upon, we've got to run a CT and then we'll make a decision. We have to run a blood test that will make a decision based upon what it says in Merck Manual.
So, we have created a medical technician that we call a doctor these days, unfortunately.
Instead of them actually beat a doctor and assessing the patient from a clinical point of view based upon their years of wisdom that they've had and that they've gained from other doctors that have preceded them.
So, you need to find somebody whose Lyme letter that will say, yes, I'd rather treat your gut and fix your gut than treat you with Lyme disease three months down the road with a chronic Lyme and have you deal with this for the next 10 years.
So, I know there's negative effects of doxocycline or a boxicillin. I'm not an antibiotic giant antibiotic advocate for any other disorders. I'd rather have, if you even have a strep to go through it so that you develop antibodies to that strep, but for Lyme disease that doesn't hold it at all.
You have got to get an antibiotic right away. So, bottom line, this is my opinion. You need to take it to your doctor.
So, my opinion is that if you have acute Lyme symptoms of flu, etc., in Lyme season and you live in Lyme country, you're better off treated with an antibiotic right away.
And how do you know if that was it? Honestly, if you jumped on the board and you felt super sick, I got the flu or something and you took an antibiotic and you'd feel better right away.
If it was a viral flu and you took an antibiotic for three days, it probably would not touch your symptoms at all.
You would have zero relief of your symptoms and then you could quit the antibiotic because you don't need any more damage from the antibiotic because it's not going to do you any good.
So, you have to use some wisdom here and do some investigation. But if you don't catch acute stage Lyme, while it is still a bloodboard or extracellular, the chance of it going to intracellular is very, very high.
And then we're playing on a completely different ball field. It's a different game. Once we move from acute stage Lyme to chronic stage two, or auto viewed, finally, stage your phase three, it's a different disease.
It's a completely different problem. So, if you ever know any face that has that disease, you need to feel further because it's a tough one.
So, there's a window of opportunity. Just literally a window. That window of opportunity of being able to kill Lyme disease in the acute phase is literally a window. Once you have that one bacteria that goes intracellular, it's over.
You might dock down all your symptoms with that antibiotic, but that one bacteria is replicated within that one cell. And within a few months, all your symptoms can come back again. There'll be different symptoms. There'll be in that chronic stage.
So, that window, how big is that window? What's the length of that window? It's different for everybody. I've had patients where that window of opportunity was missed after two days.
So, literally, it could be missed after hours. So, once the burrelia goes into your body, it could go intracellular immediately, unfortunately.
Most of the time the window is as great as 30 days, but maybe I shouldn't have said most even. Many of the times it's as great as 30 days. I've even seen people feel like they were cured. They took an antibiotic 45 days after their initial symptoms.
And that was 10 years ago. They've never had symptoms again. So, their window of opportunity was greater. But it really depends on your body. It depends on your immune system. It depends on aggressiveness and the virility of that burrelia that entered your body and how much of it did.
So, there's just too many factors to estimate with that.
Take home on this. Again, it's the same as last one. Treat acute phase Lyme as soon as possible with antibiotics. Now, you have to go to your medical doctor to do that. I'm just giving you my opinion.
So, if you're going to treat it with antibiotics, then you have to go back to all the leaky gut sides and you've got to heal your gut afterwards. But I'd rather heal your gut afterwards than to be dealing with a chronic stage Lyme.
And if you typically, if you don't get instant relief of your symptoms, or the symptoms fever, chill, rash, all these hyper-TH water response symptoms, if you don't get instant relief of it, you have either missed the window or it's not mine. Maybe it's a virus that you have.
But you're still that prophylactic response is much better than dealing with a chronic Lyme.
Again, you could call our office for help at any time or visit our websites too. All right. Talk to you soon. We'll get into the phase two next week.